The  PiBo is designed as a personal companion robot for single people.
As such, it offers a whole bunch of organizational and social aspects.
For example, it'll read you the news, it'll tell you the trending topics,...
...it will remind you of upcoming appointments, tell you the weather, tell you a joke.
It'll basically be your little robotic friend.
The PiBo stands about 15 inches tall and has both articulated legs and arms,...
...allowing it to wave at you as well as dance around.
It's really cute.
Now, there are a number of ways you can control the PiBo.
It responds to voice commands,  it also has a dedicated smartphone app...
...available for both IOS and Android.
It's even got these cool QR-enabled flash cards that you can hold up.
It will read it and then perform the corresponding action.
The PiBo only speaks Korean and English at this point...
...though the language set is sure to expand in the future.
PiBo is currently only on sale in Korea where it retails for around 850 bucks.